[Music]
Mandy Moore stepped out for the premiere
of her new animated show tangled this
series I am very excited it's kind of
been seven years in the making almost
it's bizarre to be here finally talking
about it we've arrived but we also had
to get some of this is a scoop out of
the star we only have two episodes left
and your castmates told us in New York
but these episodes are going to be
stressful how would you describe them I
would concur these episodes are
stressful their emotional and as every
episode is but I think there will be
some bit of resolution and then a little
bit open-ended for the actual finale
what can you tease on leaving off Jack
and Rebecca their season I will say that
the finale episode is just milo and i
there's like a quick flash of everybody
else but the episode really follows Jack
and Rebecca before they're Jack and
Rebecca and then that's sort of the
counterpoint to that is sort of where
we've left them in 1996 so there are
some cracks in the foundation of their
relationship and it's just it's
interesting to see the juxtaposition
between who they were before they met
and who they are at this kind of really
pivotal moment in their relationship the
first season of this is us wraps up on
March 14th but Andy has some advice on
getting through the summer hiatus I'm
bummed too I miss like I miss reading
these scripts I miss being with
everybody already and we've only been
off for three weeks I would encourage
people to just watch this season again
[Music]